she put herself in danger in the pursuit
of a good story she uncovered wrongs
committed in society she traveled around
the world and she did it all in a time
when women weren't expected to do
anything beyond get married have
children and take care of the home she
lives her life very different names she
faced backlash but she never backed down
and she changed lives and she changed
journalism forever
well who was this courageous woman that
would of course be Nellie Bly a woman
ahead of her time
[Music]
though it's the name she's best known as
today
Nellie Bly wasn't actually born as such
at her birth in 1864 she was christened
Elizabeth Jane Cochran and growing up
she was indeed known by a different name
altogether and that would be pink
she was a vibrant energetic child who
never shied from attention her mother
encouraged her vivaciousness and allowed
her to dress in bright colors most other
girls and women in her hometown of
Cochran Pennsylvania were wearing drab
colors of brown black grey and white but
pink stood out she had to she had 13
brothers and sisters to contend with for
attention after all the town was
actually named after Bligh's father
Judge Michael Cochran judge Cochrane
unfortunately passed away at an early
age and Bly was only six years old when
it happened her father did not have a
will and his death left the family
impoverished Bligh's mother remarried
but the marriage turned out to be a
disaster a new husband lies stepfather
was a violent drunk when dies mother had
finally had enough of this mistreatment
she filed for divorce at only 14 years
old but I was called upon to testify at
the divorce trial she had to speak up
about what she had seen this violent man
do and how he had mistreated her mother
true to her personality even then she
was honest and witty even in what must
have been an incredibly difficult
situation for a young teenager during
the trial she told the court my
stepfather has been generally drunk
since he married my mother and when
drunk he is very cross
he is cross sober to the whole ordeal
made an impression on Bly in the era she
was living in marriage was supposed to
be the ultimate goal for a woman but
having seen her mother's experiences
blind knew that marriage didn't always
need a secure future or even happiness
lie she decided that she was going to
make her mark on the world all by
herself
initially I went to school for a career
in teaching for a woman that was one of
the only career paths available at the
time she was a good writer but she
wasn't a good student
then after only one semester she
couldn't afford the tuition and her
mother needed help at home so she had to
leave school she moved with her mother
and siblings to Pittsburgh where they
ran a boarding house for income one day
Blythe picked up a local newspaper and
was aghast at column she read the title
it was enough to set her off because it
was what girls are good for the actual
contents well those were outright
angering the column asserted that women
were good for nothing but staying at
home and giving birth and when it came
to working women well the writer called
them a monstrosity why she wasn't want
to sit idly by and let something she
disagreed with as much as this passed by
she drafted up a response using the
pseudonym lonely orphan girl her
response caught the attention of the
papers editor George Madden but as she
had written it under a pseudonym he had
no way to identify and get in touch with
blind he was so impressed though that he
didn't give up he put an advertisement
in the Pittsburgh dispatch asking Ling
Li orphan girl to contact the paper and
reveal her identity and well why did he
do this when he wants to give her a job
Bly responded to the advertisement and
was given the chance to write a column
on a trial basis after a column was
published in the Pittsburgh dispatch
Madden hired her for a full-time job
while at the dispatch Cochran officially
adopted the name that the world would
come to remember of course that would be
Nellie Bly she worked for only $5 a week
but she had a platform to share her
ideas about women's independence well I
also began the work that would make her
famous outing social wrongs as an
undercover reporter she combines the two
messages by going undercover as a
factory worker and writing an expose on
the poor conditions the women faced as
they tried to earn pennies to help feed
their families she also wrote about the
unfair treatment of women who were in
divorce proceedings a topic she knew a
thing or two about because of her
mother's experience but her articles
were controversial and advertisers don't
like controversy sound familiar
they started to pull their ads from The
Dispatch fans the publisher got nervous
if she was going to cause problems for
their bottom line they didn't see the
value in keeping Bly in this role that
was so atypical for a woman at the
so they put her where women writers
usually works the fashion and society
pages Bly wasn't really happy with this
move in 1887 is only 23 years old
she moved by herself to New York City
she didn't have a job when she went to
the big city in fact she was unemployed
for months she wasn't willing to give up
though and kept visiting officers and
applying for work after four months she
hit the jackpot the New York world
offered to let her try out an assignment
run by Joseph Pulitzer the paper was a
prominent publication and Bly she was up
to the job one of her first assignments
at the New York world became her most
famous it also made a difference for the
treatment of some of society's most
vulnerable people in the late 19th
century the mentally ill were locked up
and isolated from society one place they
were sent in New York was the women's
lunatic asylum on Blackwell's Island and
Bly and her editors well they wanted to
get into that institution she was eager
to do so even though she didn't know how
she was going to get out all she was
told in preparation for this assignment
was write up things as you find them
good or bad give praise and blame as you
think best and the truth all the time
she spent days preparing practicing
facial expressions to make herself seem
as out of it as possible then she went
to a boarding house to spend the night
while there she pretended to be afraid
of everything at the house she spent
hours just staring in the wall and
saying nothing in short she simply did
her best to act insane it works and the
head of the boarding house called the
cops and Bly was taken away the police
had her analyzed by doctors at the
Bellevue Hospital Bly claimed to have an
easier and her case caught the attention
of the media though no one recognized
her as a journalist ultimately the
doctors were able to recommend that this
young pretty and apparently insane women
be committed to Blackwell Island now
even before she arrived at the asylum
she had a first bit of information for
her expose asylums apparently weren't
all that hard to get into when she
arrived that this observation was
cemented for her as she met other
patients he didn't seem to have all that
much reason to be locked up and away
from society once she was in the asylum
Bly didn't act at all she decided to
just be herself and interestingly this
didn't arouse suspicion at all in fact
it actually did the opposite Bly later
observed the more sane Lee I talked and
acted the crazier I was thought to be
daily life it was tough at the asylum
well I was forced into cold baths and
was freezing most of the time that she
was committed my teeth chattered and my
limbs were loose flashed with blue and
cold suddenly I got one after the other
three buckets of water over my head
ice-cold water - into my ears my eyes my
nose my mouth
the food was horrific dirty water served
alongside rotting meat gruel and nearly
inedible bread patients ate in areas
surrounded by waste and with rats
crawling around their feet their days
were spent sitting on hard benches and
some patients were even tied together in
her initial newspaper report since later
in a published book
well I described the horrific treatments
of silent patients and how it might be
making the patient's even worse she
wrote what accepting torture would
produce insanity quicker than this
treatments here is a class of women sent
to be cured I would like the expert
physicians who are condemning me for my
action which has proven their ability to
take a perfectly sane and healthy woman
shut her up and make her sit from 6:00
a.m. to 8:00 p.m. on straight back
benches do not allow her to talk or move
during these hours give her no reading
and let her know nothing of the world or
its doings give her bad food and harsh
treatment and see how long it will take
to make her insane two months would make
her a mental and physical wreck Bly
lasted ten days of Blackwell islands she
was released when the paper contacted
the asylum and asked for her release two
weeks later the piece was published in
the New York world and it grabs the
attention of the country people were
outraged and we're calling for change
grand jury was convened and Bly joins
them in devising a series of changes
that needed to be made at the asylum the
New York Department of Charities in
Corrections had a million dollars added
to its budget to help with improvements
to the facilities that had oversaw and
overall safer and more humane conditions
and treatments were implemented at the
asylums Bly became a celebrity she was
praised for her bravery and her
willingness to speak out about societal
ills but her work was far from over even
with her fame she kept up undercover
reporting the same year she went
undercover at the asylum Bly also went
undercover for a piece of a lighter
nature she wanted to find out about the
active industry in New York City that
sought to find women husbands she wrote
this has been getting interested me I
did not want to marry but I was as
interested as a little boy with a
dynamite cartridge on another occasion
she wrote about us
New York industry baby vine and she
indeed took on the New York government
exposing the actions of a prominent
lobbyist who was essentially bribing
lawmakers Nellie Bly had no shortage of
topics to write on and no shortage of
courage to drive her forward in her
investigations but her appetite for
adventure wasn't fully sated by writing
articles about the seedy goings-on of
New York City in 1888 she was 24 years
old she had an idea she wanted to travel
around the world and she wanted to do it
faster than Jules Verne's fictional
character of Phileas Fogg and of course
she wanted to write about it in the
paper although she'd proven herself from
her past assignments Bly it still faced
reticence from her editors women working
was quite difficult for the times women
traveling by themselves was adding a new
layer of defiance to the norms they
wanted to send a man around the world
and not Nellie as she later wrote the
reaction to her request was along the
lines of it is impossible for you to do
it was the terrible verdict in the first
place you are a woman and you would need
a protector and even if it were possible
for you to travel alone you would need
to carry so much baggage that it would
detain you and making rapid changes
besides you speak nothing but English so
there is no use talking about it no one
but a man can do this and so what was
her response to this very well start the
man and I'll start the same day for some
other newspaper and beat him it took a
year but her editors were eventually
convinced that she could make the
journey at that time women travelled
with suitcases full of clothes and were
often attended by escorts but by again
showed that she was ahead of her time
when the time came for her to depart on
her trip around the world in 1889 she
boarded the ship or Gustav Victoria by
herself and with only two small bags she
wore a dress at an overcoat and kept a
few hundred dollars in a bag tied around
her neck the first part of her trip
though it was tough Bly got seasick and
couldn't hold down food the only thing
that made her feel better was sleeping
at one point she slept for so long that
the ship's crew thought that she had
died in her cabin she landed in England
and went on to France in France she met
Jules Verne the man who inspired the
trip from France she traveled to Egypt
Ceylon Hong Kong and Japan in China she
visited a leper colony along the way she
traveled aboard ships and rickshaws and
trains even riding horses when needed to
back home in the United States her
readership was kept updated via
Telegraph all the time Bly was traveling
the world people were keeping her
close eye on the dispatchers that she
sent from abroad they had more than a
passing interest in her venture for
there was a prize at stake the New York
world had decided to make the most of
Bly strips who drive up their audience
and build their brands they offered a
trip to Europe for the person who was
closest to guessing on blinds return
time to her starting points people made
guesses literally down to the second
meanwhile they were also following
another trip around the world upon
hearing of Blythe stunt a rival New York
newspaper decided they couldn't let the
New York world get all the attention so
they sent a female reporter of their own
around the globe Elizabeth bisland left
New York heading the opposite way
traversing the United States first
before heading across the Pacific
bisland took four days longer than Bligh
to travel the world the final leg of
Blythe's global trip was across the
Pacific Ocean she made her way across
the world's largest ocean on the RMS
oceanic but the ship hit rough weather
on the crossing Bly was two days later
than she had plans for her arrival back
to the US she doesn't barked in San
Francisco and boarded a private train
take her back to the East Coast 72 days
after departing aboard a ship in Hoboken
New Jersey she was back not only had she
beaten Phineas Fogg fictional record she
had set a world record of her own indeed
Nellie Bly had once again proven her
naysayers wrong she said I always have a
comfortable feeling that nothing is
impossible if one applies a certain
amount of energy in the right direction
when I want things done which is always
at the last moments and I am met with
such an answer it's too late I hardly
think it can be done I simply say
nonsense if you want to do it you can do
it the question is do you want to do it
well I published the book about her
adventure and the New York world was
happy with the increased attention they
received thanks to Bly but apparently
they were not happy to give Bly a bonus
insulted of this she resigns she didn't
have a job but she wasn't suffering
quite the opposite she had become a
national celebrity her religion name
were worth money so popular had she
become with her adventure around the
world and by this point she wasn't even
30 within three years of her departure
the New York world while they wanted her
back she started writing for the paper
again in 1893 once again taking on
investigative assignments these
assignments had the goal of rooting out
corruption mistreatment
although she had always said that she
had no plans to marry and had indeed
lived out her life in defiance of the
expectations of women I eventually met a
man and decided to settle down in 1895
she met and married a 73 year old man I
was just 31 her husband Roger seaman was
the head of the ironclad manufacturing
industry marriage didn't mean that
flight was ready to become a housewife
and not work quite the opposite in fact
she started to get involved with the
manufacturing company offering designs
for products and helping oversee its
operations two of the designs she
created for the company were patented a
milk can and a garbage can in 1896 she
quit working for the New York world to
focus more of her time at the ironclads
manufacturing company when her husband
died in 1904 she even took over as its
president her time in that role lasted
less than a decade as the company filed
for bankruptcy in 1911 when the company
failed blind chumps right back into
watching you best and that was reporting
the women's suffrage movement was in
full swing and why I wrote about the
marches and calls for the vote in the
latter half of the 1910s she covered
World War one giving her another
groundbreaking title she was the first
female war correspondent in the United
States fully back into journalism she
got her own column in the New York
Journal in 1919 but sadly her return to
writing didn't last long in 1922 when
she was only 57 years old blind
contracted pneumonia the oldest would
prove to be the only thing that could
keep her down On January the 27th 1922
dye lost her life to pneumonia at San
Marcos Hospital in New York City
fittingly the next day's edition of the
Evening Journal called her the best
reporter in America
nanni Bly was a trailblazer not just for
women but for all journalists her
writing made a difference in people's
lives effecting change in government and
inspiring and lighting people's
imaginations from an early age she
showed great courage she knew what she
wanted and she went for it
letting nothing especially not the fact
that she was a woman stand in her way as
she was a writer
perhaps her own words sum up her life
best I said I could and I would and I
did so I really hope you enjoyed that
episode of biographic if you did there's
a couple of things you could do right
now one is hit that like button below
also if you want more stuff like this we
put out brand new videos every Monday
and every Thursday so hit that subscribe
button below and subscribe button
doesn't do what it used to on YouTube if
you actually want to get a notification
about these videos please do hit that
Bell button next to the subscribe button
and that'll send you a notification
every time every Monday and Thursday
when we put out a new video also if you
want to watch something else right now
stuff from the archive over there on the
right and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]